today's topic Liz oh she was at a NBA
basketball game and she was wearing an
outfit that revealed her booty but she
started Fung on and at one point the
Jumbotron camera zoomed in on her and
she was dancing then she turned around
and she was twerking and you could see
her ass just jumping up and down so
everyone went crazy be like hey man
that's inappropriate all this good stuff
and so loser decided to response let's
take a look never ever let somebody stop
you or shame you from being yourself
like this is who I've always been
now everyone's looking at it and your
criticism can just remain your criticism
and the happiest I've ever been
I'm surrounded by love and I just want
to spread that love and also spread
these cheeks and you know if you really
really don't like my ass you can kiss it
cuz kissing it makes it go away I
promise live your life we're making a
thing out of something that's not even a
thing like if you don't want to look at
that don't look at that if that's not
your thing don't look at it but you know
if you want to spread it look like you
spread your cheeks go away go go and do
your things you read it like peanut
butter on beautiful bread peanut booty I
love that yeah I'm the baseball bat but
that's different story
that way you wear
where you went where you right now where
they go where they go breathing I'm
conflicted on one hand when I go to
games I don't see a man in a speedo same
thing for girls and thongs so that was
like my first instead of basketballs of
especially is like a family game a lot
of people bring their kids that was my
first time when I thought about it I was
just like women come with their titties
popping out their turtlenecks the
cheerleaders are wearing booty shorts
and their titties are popping out their
bras you know like I know I feel some
type of way but what I'm feeling doesn't
seem just too fine
does that make sense yeah switch from
her to the cheerleader like basically
sexualisation women's unacceptable
switch to so this is one of those
situations when like I feel some type of
way but it's not just a fight I mean I'm
sure there are some people who felt some
type of way because of the fact that
she's large I don't care about that
what's me not anybody didn't I would
have done the same thing it would have
been like were you doing yeah Janet
Jackson had a whole bunch of heat
because you know her boobie was out and
it was Zenit it was not big it was a
thing because a boobie was out uh-huh so
I don't think it has to do with the
skinny or whatever it's a wardrobe that
mouth I think it probably became bigger
news because it was Liz oh yeah and
because also she's large woman probably
became even bigger but no pun intended
why'd you do that but I guess it kind of
raises what did you do that is it
because she's thicker than a bowl of
oatmeal
[Music]
officer and several different occasions
he had no problem whatsoever hitting on
the hundred carpet officer on the
audiotape trying to pick her up and
sitting there in a bowl you was right so
I think I think this discussion really
this topic really has to raise the
discussion of life what's acceptable for
you to wear in public
in what context we seem to be fine with
the sexualization of women on the field
but if it's in the stands it's weird but
I don't understand what the difference
is to be honest like where's the
consistency where is the logic you know
if we analyze it without emotions if you
look at the UFC yeah same thing green
girls the ring girl but I think you'll
see being different than basketball
games basketball games are family games
you have sees clearly for adults true
you know I mean that's the context that
has to be kept fair right so that was
like the one thing that made me feel
like I look at a UFC game is she's
shaking her ass I wouldn't care fair it
just brings up an interesting discussion
because I didn't know how to feel about
this and maybe that's the whole point
maybe we're society don't know how we
feel about what's acceptable I think as
a dude I probably shouldn't be the one
to determine what this conversation is
it's probably women who should lead it
that being said I am interested in what
the parameters are look maybe this is
just meant to be a discussion so we want
to hear from you guys in the comments
below what do you guys say do you think
this is acceptable for a basketball game
if not in what context is it acceptable
and if it is tell us why we want to kind
of have this discussion and where this
needs to go but otherwise she's free to
do what you want so I have no problem
with it pretty much not happy lives
though if you're listening to this yeah
oh my god yeah bubble yeah year y'all
wanna do the thing do the thing the
tingling the school bell rings then I
offend for gough I feed on bling a year
if you wanna do ten things do them
things throw bubble at everybody
[Music]